TODAY WE GOT CONFIRMATION OF
THAT FACT COURTESY OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THEY WROTE "THE FOLDERS WERE
ARRAYED BY AGENTS, NOT JUST
THROWN, ARRAYED BY AGENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO AFTER BEING REMOVED
FROM WHAT THE FILING INDICATED
WAS MR. TRUMP'S OFFICE.
THEY WERE NOT DISCOVERED
SCATTERED ON THE FLOOR.
JOINING US NOW IS CHRIS BEDFORD,
SENIOR EDITOR AT
"THE FEDERALIST."
CHRIS, IS THERE ANY REASON WHY,
LET'S SAY DONALD TRUMP'S LAWYERS
COULDN'T BE PRESENT IF THE DOJ
WAS JUST GOING TO PUBLISH THE
DOCUMENTS ALL OVER THE INTERNET.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
CHARADE?
>> I THINK THE DOJ IS ON HIS
HEELS.
THEY ACTUALLY BELIEVE AFTER
SEVEN YEARS OF LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, BEING ABLE TO PULL THE
WOOL OVER REPUBLICANS' EYES.
GETTING GOOD REPUBLICANS LIKE
SENATOR JEFF SESSIONS TO STAND
BACK.
PEOPLE LIKE MITT ROMNEY TO VOTE
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
PEOPLE WERE STILL GOING TO BUY
THIS AND BUY THEIR SECRETS.
AFTER THEY RAIDED THE
PRESIDENT'S HOUSE.
IF YOU ARE RATING A POLITICAL
OPPONENTS HOUSE, YOU BETTER HAVE
A DARN GOOD REASON YOU BETTER BE
VERY RIGHT WITH IT.
AFTER SEVEN YEARS OF LYING, THEY
TRIED TO SAY IT WAS SECRETS AND
THEN THEY SAID THE NUCLEAR WORD
TO SCARE EVERYONE.
THEN THEY HAD IMPLYING IT WAS
RUSSIAN SPYING AND THEN THEY
RELEASED THAT COMPLETE AND FAKE
AND EMPTY AFFIDAVIT.
THEY ARE COMING OUT WITH THIS
PICTURE OF DOCUMENTS.
THEY HAVE NOT MADE A CASE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE ONUS IS ON THEM.
THEY'VE ALREADY BECOME AN
INTERNET MEME AND THANK GOODNESS
FINALLY REPUBLICAN SENATORS AND
CONGRESSMEN AND PUNDITS ARE
IMMEDIATELY --
NO ONE IS SITTING ON ENHANCING
LESS WAIT-AND-SEE.
EVERYONE IS LOOKING TO THE DOJ
AND FBI SAY YOU SHOW THE
EVIDENCE.
IF YOU RATE YOUR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS HOUSE THE
UNITED STATES, YOU BETTER HAVE A
DARN GOOD REASON YOU BETTER
PRIVY TO US AND NOT SAY IT'S TOO
SECRET FOR THE KIDS.
>> Pete: THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE, ANOTHER
EFFORT TO ATTEMPT TO TOPPLE
DONALD TRUMP SAID NOTHING TO SEE
HERE.
THE FBI.
IT'S ALL ABOVE BOARD.
>> TRUST THE FBI.
THEY'RE JUST DOING THEIR JOB.
IT'S NOT A PARTISAN EFFORT.
AND SO MAR-A-LAGO, IT CONCERNS
ME.
I DON'T KNOW IF SOME OF THE
MATERIAL HE CARRIED TO
MAR-A-LAGO COMPROMISES OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Pete: SO IT'S NOT A
PARTISAN EFFORT BECAUSE THEY ARE
DOING OUR BIDDING.
YOU MENTION RUSSIA.
HOW MUCH OF THIS COMES BACK TO A
NEVER-ENDING OBSESSION WITH
RUSSIA GATE THAT THEY JUST CAN'T
QUIT, THAT THOSE SECRETS ARE
GOING TO SIT IN THOSE FILES
UNTIL DONALD TRUMP COULD
PERSONALLY DELIVER THEM TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY ALWAYS
BELIEVE.
I WOULD GIVE CHAIRMAN THOMPSON
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT HAD
THIS HAPPEN SEVEN YEARS AGO.
IF THE FBI RAIDED SOMEONE AS
PROMINENT AS FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY WOULD SAY
OH, MY GOSH, WHAT HAPPENED?
BUT WE KNOW BETTER NOW BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN.
THE STEELE DOSSIER HAS COME
APART.
FBI AGENTS HAVE DISHONORED
THEMSELVES, FORCED TO RESIGN.
PEOPLE WALKED OUT OF THE
BUILDING OVER THE SORT OF STUFF.
THEY DON'T HAVE OUR TRUST
ANYMORE.
THE FBI.
THAT'S ACTUALLY HEALTHY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD NOT
JUST LOOK AT THE FBI ARRESTING
OR RAIDING POLITICAL OPPONENTS
HOMES.
SAY THAT'S OKAY.
WE TRUST HIM.
WE SHOULD DEMAND ANSWERS.
THE ONUS IS ABSOLUTELY ON THEM.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS CHANGED
FROM QUESTIONING THE FBI TO
DOING THEIR BIDDING.
RIGHT NOW THE PLURALITY OF
INDEPENDENCE ACCORDING TO
POLLING THE MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING HOLD ON,
FBI.
THE BALL IS IN YOUR COURT.
YOU SHOW US WHAT YOU HAVE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE DON'T TRUST
YOU.
>> Pete: THEIR N